[Musik]
[Applaus]
gestern haben gut geschlafen ja nicht
nur irgendwelche gefeiert
keine ahnung wer das scala von 1 200
waste unserem clubs gartner
während du deine abonnenten gartenpflege
hässlich ist oder es gibt keine schnitte
reform mitten in der innenstadt von der
schön und wir sind irgendwo angreifen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie schmeckt
[Musik]
du dich als erfahrenen und guten
autofahrer bezeichnen
ich bin jetzt in meiner wohnung
angekommen und letzten bisher für
platzwunde nächsten tagen des ganzen
aktion so gut sie auch war leider drei
tage flöten die eigentlich hätte lernen
will
wir sehen uns so einen wk 4 stunden wir
haben jedoch beide sorgfältig
geschnittenen also die irgendwie hierher
gewählt habe ich auch von meinem tage
aber nochmal ganz kurzen deutschland ist
dabei das thema plan auf meinen kanal
räten aber dafür gehe ich glaub ich mal
nach unten
doch eigentlich schon seit eineinhalb
jahren habe ich dann mein studium
pflichtpraktikum in düsseldorf gemacht
und wollte euch einfach mal mitten durch
zeigen die man im alltag überhaupt weil
das duo alles sehr stressig werkeln habe
ich sogar robert von studio 1 70 schon
gefragt ob er mir mit acht effekt
irgendwelche coolen 3d elemente bauen
kann mit uhrzeiten und so aber irgendwie
habe ich halt niedrig ist anfang
wirklich alles vorbereitet haben
diejenigen und 17 gemacht was ich machen
könnte was innovativ denken ich habe nie
wirklich mit der kamera gekauft und
angefangen zu bloggen
der vorstand allerdings noch keine zeit
hatte ich videos autopsie habe ich
bestelle mir die kleinen freuen sind
schon fehler etwa in begleitung von
einander ist aber die ganzen reaktionen
auf diesem blog aus diese ultra
politiker folge feierte von witzig sein
aber andererseits auch wirklich ihre
freunde und kollegen von mir dass ich
mir einfach gedacht hey wir können jetzt
eigentlich wirklich merkt dass die blogs
machen dann habe ich mir überlegt dass
sie theoretisch ja wir machen könnte ich
meine normalen konnten täglich dringen
aber dann ab und zu würden quasi anderen
tag x weggestrichen der online halten
blog wenn irgendwas wird wie jetzt
passiert oder soweit er richtig braucht
doch auch dann mit
ketten daumen über die im video und
schreibt mir kommentare mit wenigen
plätze da und dann sehen wir uns morgen
einen anderen julia bohn irrt mich auf
den film blue card abonniert